emily is with us in Fort Lauderdale
hi Emily how are you I'm great Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
okay so yeah and I have about $300,000
in that most of it is school loans he we
have combined about $60,000 saved most
of that is him working over the past
five years because I've been in school
we both read Total Money Makeover we
have the emergency fund of a thousand
dollars and he's very very nervous about
putting a huge chunk of that sixty
thousand dollars that he has when are
you getting married
2020 why oh why why so long because he
says that he wants more financial
stability basically because I haven't
been working and he wants you on
marketability yeah well that's bull you
got $300,000 in debt you're not gonna
have stability by 2020 not with $60,000
so number one there's not a we I tell
you what hold on man when we get back to
this break I'll walk you through this
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
all right I'm talking with Emily in Fort
Lauderdale between the two of them her
and her fiance have $300,000 in debt
60,000 dollars in savings he wants a
financial stability before they get
married they're scheduled to be married
in 2020 I was pushing back against that
as the old guy on the phone so anyway
all right Emily let's start again you
ready okay okay
number one there is not a we legally
speaking until you're married okay and
so you have how much student loan debt
mine alone is 250 okay so you're the
majority of the student loan debt and he
has 50 yes and he has 60,000 in savings
yes he could completely wipe out his
debt and he makes so much a year who
makes between 65 and 75 depending on how
much overtime he takes okay were I to
coach him as a single young man which he
is who's engaged I would tell him to pay
off all of his debt today and have
$10,000 in the bank and begin to rebuild
his savings because he's engaged to a
girl with a lot of student loan debt and
he's got to get he's got to get ready to
marry her okay
that would be my coaching to him were he
to follow the Dave Ramsey plan okay
because that's the shortest method or
the shortest distance between broke and
wealth is to get out of debt it's the
fastest way to build wealth and it's not
to play footsie with debt while you got
money and the savings to pay it off okay
now that are you in school still I just
graduated passed my boards I start my
new jobs next Monday pasture boards so
you are a doc doctor physical therapy
yes okay apt your PT for 250 grand under
and and out-of-state tuition and you got
hammered okay so you're gonna be making
what probably 80 60 80 between 75 and 80
yeah okay all right and so what I would
recommend I don't think you have to be
you know you have a job you've got a
degree he's got a job he's got a degree
he's debt-free then the two of you
married would have a household income
approaching 150 thousand dollars and
clear up a 250,000 dollar debt very very
quickly like in probably less than three
years
that's after we're married because at
that point we have debt and we have a
household income and where everything's
combined after marriage okay right and
so I would not wait to get married you
know it's not going to I mean his
requiring you to pay down your student
loan debt to get married is kind of
weird no that's not what I meant he just
like because I wasn't because I haven't
been working yeah but you are yeah okay
if you got married in the spring you're
gonna have your $80,000 income he's
gonna have his $65,000 income he's gonna
be debt-free with $10,000 in the bank
and you know you're gonna get married
and you're gonna be making a really good
income but I have a lot of debt to clean
up and that's what I would do I mean if
you want to get married this summer for
instance in 19 instead of 20 I just I
don't tell people to wait until they get
their finances straightened out to be
married
I tell them to wait until they're on the
same page and in agreement about where
we're going and that's what I would do
so anyway that's my two cents and so you
got more advice than you were looking
for